welcome to this video please EU seven or
seven no and from Israel and his written
1933 don't get two players below 2000
too often he's playing the color they
are not a bad opening it's very solid
not overly ambitious but very playable
of course yeah what can i do i can't
play with d5 yeah I very often play with
the exchange in and set up a hedgehog
it's some way to keep as many pieces on
the board as some yeah as possible white
still can can exchange some 94 it's not
very ambitious I also could have taken
twice on e4 and have no problems
whatsoever but it's difficult to play
this type of position for a win okay
come on let's this is this is
strategically speaking a good exchange
okay and try try b5 the abbey five tries
to
fix the pawns on dark squares I should
have done to be six really hmm yeah the
issue is now he's attacking b5 and I
need to need to spend a move to protect
it and then yes Bishop g5 and exchange
even more more material which is not
threatening but able play Bishop g5 and
and exchange even more it's just try to
swap everything oh it does not play it
now all this is I think actually a
mistake I mean even if it is a very bit
of a destructive move Bishop g5 it's a
good one the bishop is not a good piece
and you really should exchange it okay
let's see how to proceed Queen yeah he
still as Bishop g5 after Queen c7 okay
let's play play some strengthening moves
we really playing see fire would be
surprising okay
I may be but ok my knight on d5 is real
rock it's impossible to to get rid of
really and now he's playing it him not
sure why he rejected it before and now
he's going for it I wonder about Quincy
form yeah this is not bad news it's a
bit irritating at least and it's
tempting for him maybe they had to
exchange to exchange greens and this
would really help me a lot of I could
take with the B porn that have my rook
open nice not going for it but now um
now I'm able to play a fire fried see
maybe no no he's not I was thinking
about maybe you can take a plane igf-i
that sub stage but I liked him I need to
control g5 this is better with the age
six is possible if he takes Knight X is
completely fine and then a five before
this is of course my idea I'd like to
get this minority attack roll rolling
group c 8 can be a further strengthening
of this idea on Queen D 5 D 5 is also
good square for the Queen the Queen on
c4 made sure that he cannot easily play
B 3 C 4 and maybe he is going for that
now possible okay here on yeah probably
best to go here
yeah I don't know c4 is this really a
threat I think it might make sense okay
maybe maybe he's got no yeah he can't
play a 94 this is what I was getting at
he can play that but I don't think it's
it's terribly dangerous I can carry on
with the rook yeah but the light is not
not badly placed on the square quite
clearly not maybe queen a five I want to
get I only want to get rid of those
pieces they are really annoying Queen I
can go Quinn g3 ike I've got to bring g6
now i'm i don't really make don't really
get get anywhere with that try to tempt
them to the Queen trade but oh no it's
doing it well now he has d4 d5 this was
this awesomest a key I think it should
have played d5 now I get the blockade
set up again well let's say the this
nice position on d5 it's not a real
blockade and the classical sense okay
may 5 a-5 and before I am yeah
if I go before I need to be aware of the
possibility to take take c4 must be a
must be cautious with that I could try
to get the night to see form yeah well
maybe maybe okay I let's cover that when
a fire first and i also have prepared
the King activation getting the King to
the center cannot be bad really okay
well I'm thinking about Knight b6 to see
for ya yeah this should allow to make
some progress right on c4 would attack
all night on a four-night on a4 is also
possible yeah yeah dedee pfeiffer but
now I have a majority here let's let's
see he's some trouble on b2 now oh this
is surprising I don't think this is good
brilliant the v2 con but first I need to
play a 5 making sure that on fyv for
yeah this is a position where I'm
basically a pawn up because the sea for
porn the sea for porn nullifies the bit
to bond I just make sure that there's
never ever going to be moved maybe I
should play yeah let's do that ya know d
5 is gone probably shoulda played rookie
you want to make sure you can defend it
just a 4 right take first this matter
now maybe maybe just take here there's
no reason to advanced yet I can always
do that now I have two protected passes
quite resigned yeah yeah this was
somewhat passive position for quite a
while around here I don't think I should
exchange Queens I mean it's not
certainly not a decisive mistake but it
helps me that Queens off helps me to
improve my position you should probably
just go Queen somewhere to g3 for
example and continue with the no k
position well this shouldn't be terrible
but it gets it gets tricky quite quite
quickly yeah this is this is just more
comfortable for like I have this ideas
with the min minority attack and always
this Knight to c4 possibility now it
step-by-step goes downhill well very
difficult to defend
yeah after that yeah the problem is that
d 5 is cut off from its forces this pawn
on d5 can only be protected by a piece
and this is more of a liability than a
strength it went back yeah and this is
really not easy to play at all you
should maybe try to to get active
something like this let's say oh I
didn't choose the back button maybe
something like that possibility g6 maybe
King King up here something this is
should still be this can be tried i mean
i'm not sure that black is necessarily
winning a compass giving this is equal
but yeah maybe he has got enough counter
play on the G files possible then I
probably made some questions maybe a
five then it's not not precise I don't
need to do that really I can I can delay
that the computer wants to play a form
and go for the same ideas that I that I
went for in the game but on f4 it just
wants to keep the status quo with f6
yeah probably this is better can be
possible yeah okay thanks for watching